so let's talk now about Augustine we're
going to wrap up our our study of him
with this session yeah it book 3 about
the freedom of the will each book is set
up so it deals with a particular set of
problems this one is really dealing with
this question is divine foreknowledge
compatible with free will but you notice
you know as usual Augustine has a couple
declarations he you know goes ohaf that
he talks for a while about suicide and
whether somebody really wants to not
exist or not does that make sense and
you might say well that's kind of just a
play it's a digression he's going away
from the main argument you have
something to do with it but it takes
them some time to spell that out I'm
gonna try to skip over the decorations
as much as possible if we have time then
I'll hit on them and yeah there's also a
lot of God talk in there and sort of
religious God talk as opposed to
philosophical gods one where Augustine
is talking about you know praise God or
you know he starts to get a bit more
crece in this one doesn't even in the
other books and I think that you know if
you are religious and your religious
views more or less coincide with
Augustine then you'll find those kind of
edifying and useful but I think when
you're reading through this from a
philosophical perspective you don't
actually have to pay close attention to
that stuff it's better just to pay close
attention to the arguments the arguments
that are being being put forward because
they're by themselves you know they're
they're difficult enough and they're
dealing with some pretty deep
metaphysical topics the topics in what
we call metaphysics philosophy human
nature
even some epistemology and ethics so
let's talk about this this question of
divine
and let's just think about this concept
a bit before we start going through the
text so for knowledge that means you
know the two parts is knowing and what
does it take knowledge of something when
you say you know something you need kind
of it right so that's the difference
between saying knowing something
experiential like if you I'm going to
answer something that you don't know
from experience but you can figure out
let's say I give this piece of chalk to
you and you know you don't chew it or
anything you just swallow that good
thing for you or a bad thing for you
yeah you didn't have to think it off a
lot about that right
how many of you would say you're
confident that you know it would be a
bad thing for you to swallow this piece
of chocolate
does anybody uncertain about it
and wavering you know how do you know
that what's the basis for your knowledge
do you swallow another similar objects
and it didn't turn out well for you
probably highly hope you gather there's
there's an important consideration it's
not a food yeah we can swallow other
things and get smaller pennies yeah it's
a pretty nervous substance there's
nothing in this that's actually in the
hurt you it's probably the sheep right
yeah it could cause you to choke this is
hard stuff your stomach acid will
dissolve it pretty quick but it's gonna
hurt quite a bit on the way down and so
it's not good for you right so you
carried out a very rudimentary process
of figuring out what's good for you
what's bad for you to that that ties in
with the Augustine calls prudence and
camallo and you do this all the time
right when you're crossing nothing where
do you cross whatever you like
does anybody run across the street
randomly
why not because those cars out there the
speed limits 40 but how far how faster
those cars going a lot of the time 60
yeah and if you get hit not again
you don't know this by experience you've
never been hit by a car going 60 miles
an hour having oh you're gonna be alive
yeah well you might but you probably
wouldn't be you know running around but
you know all of you would say you know
that if you step out into 9w to sort of
leisurely walk across you're probably
gonna get tagged by somebody and it's
gonna be very bad for you to do that all
right you you don't need to put that to
the test you have knowledge about that
you have knowledge about a lot of
different things and somebody has to do
with consequences some of it has to do
with fairly more abstract things like
mathematics I mean how many of you know
what three plus six is oh right anybody
in doubt about that
this time well you know so we thought we
have a pretty good idea what knowledge
is do you know anything about your own
behavior or other people's behavior for
certain
is there anything you can say I know
this for certain what about with a high
degree of probability that's that's not
a good that moster a masochist in which
case they you know they might be like
enticing right but you're right in most
cases there's a high degree of
probability make somebody experience
pain they will also experience
unhappiness probably angry
that's very good we we can predict
things about things that I have yeah I
think you know when we were adults we
have a much better handle on this the
kids do sometimes kids will do things
just to see what happens right and you
look at me like man that was a daunting
thing to do you could have figured that
out like when I was a kid I was four
years old I took my mom's car keys and
they weren't these kind of keys they
were more like this a little bit thinner
and I stuck it into the electrical
socket and I thought it was playing
start the car you know and you couldn't
figure out what it would happen it was
110 poles knocked me backwards started
melting the key there are all sorts of
other things my mom's worried and angry
I never did that again sometimes you
have to you have to apply your knowledge
in experiential painful ways sometimes
you can't watch other people do
something stupid and say wow I'm not
doing that
that's don't stick your tongue on a week
old playground post all have you seen
somebody do that right let's go
you didn't do it right you weren't the
kid who did it you know not to do it you
actually understand also how it works
why does your Thomas stick
well because it's cold and you know
water freezes and then you're gonna get
yourself stuck and then something's
going to come along with hot water
before another you have the knowledge of
what's going to happen about future
events for knowledge is knowledge of
what is to come now your foreknowledge
is pretty limited
it's not small so does mine for example
you know you guys are taking the midterm
on Thursday I can I can sort of guess
how people are going to do but my guess
is could be way way too long you know
even you can't fully predict exactly how
you're going to do it canyon you have
some basic ideas if you how are you
going to do if you don't study at all
and you go out with your friends the
night before we have an 8 o'clock class
so let's say you go with what's Bart I'm
here to 2:30 or it was there for these
carrot that's okay you stay out till
4:00 in the morning now all of you are
underaged all your engineering folks but
you stay up till 4:00 in the morning the
night before how are you gonna do all
the testing perfect that's the strategy
I mean you know don't you if you do
something like that you're probably
gonna do poorly how much studying do you
think you let me ask you this how much
how many hours of studying do you think
if you want to do really well on the
Testament you probably do
team like 10 15 10 to 15 any other
answers or thus unreasonable to you guys
okay so you you actually can't predict
to some degree how you're going to do
but you could get to the task dad it
could be like a bad day for you and your
brain just freezes up on the other end
you could you know like stay out till
4:00 in the morning and you know some
sort of miracle could take place and the
knowledge is just like pops into your
head and you're like you know writing
you're like crazy in a hundred percent
you don't have a you know complete floor
knowledge about that and the further and
further we get out the more market kids
right what about forgotten we say God is
omniscient presumably everything is just
as totally clear for God and you know
what we consider knowledge that we can
we can be absolutely confident about
experiential knowledge of mathematics or
things like that so God knows exactly
you know when I when I drop this pen and
I'm not even sure you know what I'm
going to drop the he knows exactly all
the mathematical problems we can't solve
what he knows the answers to those what
the path that my life is going to be and
all the stuff that I don't even remember
about my you know wife going all the way
back to childhood he knows all that and
he knows all of that long before I even
exist so I was born in 1970 God knew in
1969 the entire timeline for for Gregory
Sadler and when he became dr. Gregory
Sadler and when he you know did
something stupid that got him killed or
when he died happily
old age is bad you know he knows all
those sorts of things you know a date
with on this this date you know in 1989
he knows what I had wrote down as an
answer on a test in 1982 and he knew it
before it actually took place he knew it
actually before the world existed that's
what I mean to have to buy four dollars
now if you put it that way is that
compatible three well remember what free
will means it means you are actually not
only morally responsible for your
decisions you get to pick them but if
God knows ahead of time what it is that
you're going to do are you really free
that's the problem having more knowledge
for knowledge tells you you couldn't do
otherwise then right I mean when you go
wrong with your plan you can say well
there are some factors I didn't know
about you know my foreknowledge whatever
the council's foreknowledge would mean
it doesn't really make things happen the
way they do by God he's in a different
boat isn't he he knows everything
so he knows something's gonna happen it
has to happen right he has to happen
that way then where's your freewill
yeah
it's known what one thing has to be done
you can see all the possible
opportunities and all the possible
outcomes 3 I mean these are different
consequences right it'll be a different
kind of universe at least a little part
that you're in depending on whether you
choose to study philosophy choose a
business choose to study medicine
the trouble is God already knows which
choice you make right because it's
foreknowledge
so yeah you have different choices at
this point but in a certain way you
never really have any choice you were
you were gonna go this way because God
already knew it so you to you know even
mean even though he knows like you still
chose it but he just knew
that's one of the ways you didn't go
with this there are answers to this I've
been trying to make this you know sort
of a pressing problem for you in the way
that the vote is is because of odious
was really puzzled by this a lot of
people are that was the time a bit of
time to go to the taxes so let's see
what the Modi's say voting says I am
troubled exceedingly by the question of
how God and foreknowledge of all future
events and how there can be no necessity
for us to sin notice he's worried about
how can you know how could it be our
fault when we screw up he's not worried
about how could it be a hard fall when
we do the right thing that that were
perfectly willing to say yeah that's
fine it's when we screw up when other
people screw up you know I say is it
their fault or is it really God's fault
it's got to be something small right he
says if anyone can sense an event can
happen contrary to God's foreknowledge
he's attempting to destroy the
foreknowledge of God we don't want to
get rid of that so if God foresaw the
first man would said this must be
granted by anyone who agrees with me
that God has foreknowledge of all future
maximum real easy cases just yeah
alright Adam in the Garden of Eden Adam
and Eve actually right are they going to
sin or not now you could say well God
you know we did this last metric God
made them and it gave them free will and
he said you know go do your thing don't
screw up I'm not giving you free will so
you can be a screw-up I'm giving it to
you so you do the right thing
what do you know they could do the wrong
thing and he actually knew that you know
choice one good about them to say I'm
not really interested in apples the day
all pass on that this time you know
choice to us say yeah I'll try that
now just good a needle sounds great to
me maybe maybe choice three a technology
good another like he picks up the
circumcircle swinging it around and
smacks it against the tree or something
like that runs runs away from the
situation well God already knows ahead
of time right when he's which way it's
gonna go so it kinda looks like yeah
doesn't really have a choice he says and
so the void is I don't say that God
should not create him because he created
it good northern a sin could in any way
be prejudicial to God no in creating him
God showed his goodness but I say this
since God had foreknowledge he would
spend it must have happened by necessity
this is the key term here necessity
necessity we mean it has to be that way
right necessarily it must be so the
arguments that we saw for God's
existence that people who are making
those are supposed to be necessary
artists not just possible or probable
arguments necessary arguments you can
even say this about things in the world
when I stuck that car key into that
electrical socket provided there was
actually current what must of necessity
occur I get zapped right with with the
same thing right
provided my body's actually working the
right way when you put 110 volts through
it how many have been shot before by
more than like you know an angled
battery because you're testing it like a
dummy to when you get shot that hurts
right burns and that happens the
necessity given certain conditions if
your body is working right if your
nerves are actually connected and you
get zapped you're going to feel pain so
it looks like God is for now somehow
necessitates the atoms sent or any of
our our
so he says how then is the will free
when the necessity seems so incapable
it seemed so inescapable yeah and he
brings up some other views some people
say well get rid of that take out of the
picture so we can all be free that would
be one one solution wouldn't it okay
they says others on the other hand while
not daring to deny God's providence
covers people's wide prefer to say that
Providence is weak or unjust or evils of
God you know I've got God in the picture
but God screws things up that'd be
another way you could come he and says
this is a real problem real
philosophical problem and this is a
problem where we're going to go for what
looks like a contradiction but when you
have a contradiction what's going on
some things cannot be compatible with
each other so in this case what is the
contradiction between divine
foreknowledge and free will they're
saying you can't handle you've got to
pick one or the other so either you've
got a guy who doesn't know everything or
you can have free will you can't have
fun that would be a contradiction and
this contradiction to problem solved
we're going to end up going from a
contradiction to what we call the
paradox where something looks
contradictory but it really isn't but
it's hard to wrap our heads around it's
hard to fully understand and then
hopefully by the end of that we'll get
some sort of status back
but it's going to work my steps this
isn't the kind of problem that you can
solve by sort of just saying well here's
the answer now we're done you have to
kind of think your way through it
because these are these are some real
murky issues so Augustine really gives
you two ways of approaching this and
these are not the only ways of dealing
with this problem as met in fact you're
on the right track of thinking of one
possible responses is to say wait of God
actually created us as free beings so
God knows of necessity what we're going
to do as free beings that's the route
that pants on we'll take a piece that
we're not going to read in this class
after the midterm which you could read
almost eerie towards that if you're
really interested in this Augustine is
going to do a little bit different yes
so the first thing that he does is he
tries to get the problem clarified you
know so he's talking with the gaudiya so
he says so in your opinion everything
for known by God comes about of a
necessity and after you vote it says
yeah does that seem reasonable to you
guys everything that God knows ahead of
time must be happening by necessity what
do you think yes or no this vote is
right in assuming what's your gut feel
you don't just stick with what is it
right now that's not possible to
everything God knows ahead of time it
has to happen
like and like say someone who's talking
to someone else and they choose to
insult that person and God knows if they
didn't so it was coming yeah that is
coming out of necessity well I mean
maybe God knows all the things that make
up that person right and psychologically
so he knows that at point this that
person's finally gonna snap and say the
the mean thing that they shouldn't have
said like you know versus me I this with
a bad temper made improvements on that
over the course of my life and all that
means is basically I can take more stuff
before I finally like go on you know and
which isn't a good thing
so you know God knows when that's gonna
happen you know exactly what sort of
things would be the stressors put
together and he knows that because he
knows the things that make me so
wouldn't be necessity different god I'm
like it's like the one thing there's a
God
who knows like potentially everything
that they're gonna do but then like the
other people who might do you like a
different guy so if you have a model of
a god that doesn't have 6.0 got get
surprised by stuff then that it's not an
issue right and there are some biblical
passages where it kind of looks like
that like you know think about the Tower
of Babel there's a really interesting
verse in there
okay this human being geometry and human
beings are building this building the
Tower of Babel because they're going to
reach to heaven and that God says wow I
got to put a stop to this because if
they do this who don't what these people
are gonna do that kind of sounds like
God doesn't know what's what's up right
he hasn't he's not able to predict who
knows what they're gonna do that's
saying he lacks for now and there's ways
around the Saudi when he knocks the
power down scanners everybody
back to the how do you think yeah it
kind of sounds like it's nothing because
he's walking around where are you well
presumably that could be that it's his
speed he didn't know where he's waiting
for Adam will I come out and say hey I
do or something like yeah we don't
really know with a lot with a lot of
these things in Genesis there's such
elliptical stories you know so much is
compressed into a single verse we don't
really know we probably should read too
much into and from a philosophical
perspective we're not going to get a lot
of mileage other than anybody that's
more than theology let's go on with us
what do you obviously is doing with an
audience he says pay attention reflected
tell me what will be your will tomorrow
to do wrong and right now let me ask you
this are you going to do the right thing
or the wrong thing tomorrow I mean if
you're actually hedging your bets down a
little bit of both right I'm pretty sure
I'm going to screw something up because
I live long enough quite enough
self-knowledge
but on the whole more wrong stuff for
more right stuff in the day do you know
at this point
Oh still got some who you know should
know way better than a young person a
lot of young people are actually more on
track them than other people the older
people have bad habits or things like
that you get it at least fairly
unspoiled compared to possible yeah yeah
let's say we put that problem on one
thing we actually said there are
objectively good and bad things and you
just have to decide put your name you're
gonna be a good guy tomorrow push your
button be here to make bad guys now you
can push button because you're you know
sort of being humble and you've got a
good understanding and then you actually
do a little bunch of good stuff tomorrow
so you push the wrong button we're not
able to make predictions accurate
predictions about what we're going to do
people make all the promises they don't
keep right and oftentimes they intend to
keep those promises they promise good
things but then they they don't deliver
it sometimes they actually promise me
ethics yeah I'll kill this guy for you
and then they don't deliver on that
which is a good thing
boxing's point is we don't actually have
foreknowledge of what we're going to do
tomorrow they said what about gods god
no what are you going to do tomorrow
yeah because God has poor knowledge and
then he says if God was what you were
will tomorrow and foresees with all men
mobile in the future whether they exist
now or will exist far more does he
foresee what he is going to do to the
just and the unjust and you could pick
all sorts of other examples does God
know what he plans on doing at the end
of time there's things like that
presumably yes right cuz God actually
knows his own plans so he says God for
sees clearly what
now if you want to say that and you want
to say for knowledge takes away free
will what are the implications for God
himself God not only knows what you're
gonna do
god knows what he's gonna he has more
knowledge of that does that mean God
doesn't have free will that God is
somehow necessitating God well that's a
problem yeah how could he obviously
doesn't talk about it that way but you
could say how could he give free will if
he doesn't even have it so that it looks
like even God is clocking the janitor
precisely so there's something even
higher than God that necessity so that
should lead us to you know some some
suspicions that maybe about this sort of
thing he tries another tact with this
too it has to do with happiness and he
says when you're happy are you happy
because you're when you're happy are you
actually willing to be happy are you
choosing together and the answer is yes
basically I mean you can be happy in
part because of your choices because you
do the kinds of things that actually do
make you happy
you could also be happy because you've
made the right choices and you're happy
about doing the right thing
you know if your soul is more or less in
alignment that's going to be the case so
you know when you volunteer at the soup
kitchen and you help somebody who's
homeless and even if they don't thank
you you think yourself man that was a
good thing I did I'm glad I did that
instead of just sitting at home watching
TV you're you're taking some legitimate
you know joy and something good to do
and you know you're not like unwilling
to be happy right you're not saying oh
and there are some people who don't seem
to want to be happy but they like being
miserable
complaining all the time they don't seem
to a lot of fun they like actually
they're given the option they have fun
and they like pass it up well because
they like being miserable that's what
makes them happy they're willing that
Augustine would say so you can't
actually be happy against your will
that's at least one thing there's a lot
of other things that we can be against
her
he says you know you could you could die
against your will you can be deprived of
things against your will but you can't
really be happy that you wrestle there's
at least some things that you can't be
unwilling listen then he says can you
actually will because now we know that
some things we can't do another thing he
says nothing is so fully in our power as
the will and stuff we saw this last time
right the will is what we call reflexive
it works on itself if you want to change
the direction that you're going in your
life you can steer the ship in a
different direction so by changing your
will so he says nothing is so fully in
our powers the will itself it's ready at
once and without delay to act as we will
we can truly say we grow old of
necessity why because our bodies are
like this you know if I could be sort of
shape that you guys are good
by what I'm not willing to be you know
42 years old overweight not you know
good cardiovascular health have fairly
poor sleep habits you know these sorts
of things that's some of that is a
product of my own willing right I didn't
get this size by never eating too much
avoid that you should you know good
portions right so it does live isn't it
well but at this point I'm I'm not
willing to be like this and I'm gonna
get all this and you're gonna get older
too and someday you're gonna be 40 years
and you're gonna say man I wish I was 30
I wish I was 20 it's not in your your
your choice it's something that goes
against your will we are in a little
necessity some of you guys are sick
right now did you choose to have a sinus
infection no as a matter of fact you
could have actually like done everything
you could to avoid it and it could still
hit you right yeah do you choose even
what medicine they they they decide to
give you for it or not give you for it
no it's those are against our wills are
unwilling those happen by necessity of
other things we diet necessity another
he says no one would be so mad to
venture to say it we do not will we have
at least this much when he gets it shoes
a certain amount so he says although God
before knows what will will in the
future that doesn't imply that we do not
make use of our will so let's look at
this sir choice juncture the way it's
been sort of conveyed is God's
foreknowledge and closes assesses
everything but it's not what's going on
at this point do you have a choice to
use free will at that swing and God sees
you doing that God's foreknowledge is
not making you turn your will this way
or that way God seeing what you do but
you are you seeing you do it willingly
freely at that point
why is he actually seeing you doing that
because you did that at that point
it doesn't make sense to talk about you
willing sunglasses freely that's what it
means to have a will that's what it
means to have a faculty of choice to be
able to decide
so he says foreknowledge of God which is
certain today of your does not take away
your will to be happy when you are happy
you you freely want to be happy so too
if your will the future is sinful it
will not cease to be your will because
God foreknew what was going to happen so
we're thinking about the atom we could
say yeah God wouldn't God created Adam
he like saw everything ahead of time but
he saw Adam can't this point in time
making the free choice to do the wrong
thing as he gave them a free will and
that's what it means to heaven well so
like it says our will would not be our
our will would not be a will if it was
not in our power that's what it means to
actually have a bill to have something
that can decide between different
options
he says when we will if the will is
absent we don't will this is a bad sort
of the very concept of the will
Augustine is saying there's there's kind
of a nonsense Akala t to say that I am
completely necessitated I don't have any
free will at all it's kind of
interesting this is the dead Gresham's
from Augustine back to that second when
I was teaching in the prisons I had
every once in a while I would get to
this area where we talked about are we
Tru truly three or are we not free and
if people aren't free that's people who
did crimes they they're not really
morally responsible for that right
because they didn't choose them freely
they we're gonna miss us a-- t right so
maybe they have bad upbringing and bad
neighborhood and they couldn't have
possibly done otherwise and so therefore
if that's the case it's mean cross to
punish them isn't it punish somebody for
something they couldn't help doing
that's sort of like you know if you've
got somebody who is just not good at
taking tests
and you make them take a test and they
do badly on it and then you punish them
for it you're kind of a jerk aren't you
because you're you're doing something
unfair and so I don't even guys we point
this out hey you know if this stuff is
true we're really determined we don't
really have free will
man we shouldn't be here in this prison
and then I would say and well actually I
don't have other guys in the class would
say in response wait a second if if you
don't have free well that means
everybody doesn't have free well and
that means that the people who are
punishing you are just as determined
without any choice of their own mark to
punish you and so it's perfectly fine
for there to be punishment then if you
take away free will from any group of
human beings you really have to take it
away from everybody and then you can't
complain about anything everything
becomes totally flattened down like the
in like you're talking about meaning
last class you know or the possibility
of being put to the test right
that would be that wouldn't be possible
so let's go on
and because Augustine is actually going
to give us another possible way to to
talk about this so one way we can say it
look what it means to have a will is
that you actually do have some degree of
freedom you choose freely even though
God can see another way that you could
talk about this is much more of an
aesthetic argument aesthetic meaning
having to do with beauty having to do
with the the way things you know want to
be in order for them to be to be really
good to be appeal us so he says what
about our our our soul our wills the
kind of beans you guys remember when we
talk about these different degrees of
being there was bear being and then you
know animals and play
at a certain level and that we were
above them obviously they have this
notion the Stoics also have this notion
what happens when we screw up are we
dropping down lower let me actually we
have these degrees of we has just
existence itself being sensible being
living not being able to perceive things
through the inner sense understanding
free will available and then there is a
higher level
yeah this is like you know where truth
is itself truth and the virtues in a
certain way and also got right now as
you go from the lower to the higher
things are getting better that's it's
not just that they have more being they
are better qualitatively better types of
beings and when we think about somebody
who is a bad person
they are there's something screwed up in
them Augustine is this notion of evil as
not being something that exists of its
own right evil is a corruption or a
private agent or going astray of the
good right so somebody who's a bad
person they are still a person though
aren't they
and so far as they're a bad person
they're they're bad but insofar as they
are person they are they are good so
they're good and bad at the same time
you could say the goodness of being a
person is you know part of what's being
corrupted you know there's the being of
being shot through I gotta lose myself
as an example so I get angrier that I
want to
and you know lose my temper at moments
when I shouldn't and say stupid things
because of it that's that's my not
living up to my full potential ISM yeah
as consequences for other people has
consequences for me and sometimes our
physical objects you know if I get angry
I'll throw my phone across the room well
I haven't done anything like that for a
long time but I would be a better person
did I not have that and it's not just
that that's sort of a negative thing the
positive thing for it would be for me to
be a patient person to be a person who
didn't lose my temper because I was able
to respond positively to frustration
right responding negatively to
frustration is actually my lacking
something that I want to have now I
still remain at this level don't I even
if I'm a bad human being human beings on
earth at this level they're not just at
this one let alone at this level here's
this piece of chakra where the cell
phone here's your dog or cat even if you
are a serial killer from Augustine's
perspective you are still as a human
being ontological be better than your
dog or cat even though your daughter Ken
is nice would never hurt anybody so for
maybe you know my high score squirrels
you are any a higher level so he says
when we look at things and we say that
they're not as they ought to be it's
because we compare them with yet higher
things we say everything should be like
the best but that's not necessarily the
case he says you know when we're talking
about people screwing up they're blamed
in comparison with themselves with the
way they want to be so if I'm kind of
angry or unjust or intemperate I want to
be those ways and
not comparing me you know against Bazar
Burkett you're comparing me against the
ideal me that I want to be what I would
be if I didn't screw up so he says when
we're making these sort of comparisons
were saying that God should have done
things differently and he says God
created human beings with so noble of
nature that even when stainless in there
no way it surpassed and dignity my
modeling like or by any other created
thing
so he actually attributes this to the
vice of of envy to say that we you know
things will ought to be different so
what's the upshot of that so I'm gonna
have to skip ahead very very quickly
he says God has not compelled people to
sin or a screw up because he created
them and gave them the power to choose
between sinning and not sinning he gave
them this power that's a goodness the
fact that they misuse it it still keeps
them at this level of being because
we're talking about free will so your
free will
did not you know make things lower as a
matter of fact you're in a certain way
better by having it and the universe is
actually better off with having you in
it even when you screw up just get much
further about suicide here
so it's gotta meet all nature's not only
those which were able to abide in virtue
and justice but also those that were
able screw up that's us he created them
not so that they would do that but that
they might add Beauty to the whole
whether they will to screw up or not I'm
saying screw up rather than sin to try
to put it in a false off around
a lot right if there's been no souls at
the very summit of the whole creation or
if there's been no creatures like this
the universe would not be as good if in
all of the enemas you know fear being
you know chalk and landforms and things
like that and then the living beings but
not actual rational beings it wouldn't
be as good he says if there had been no
souls at the very summit of the whole
created order such that if they chose to
sin they would weaken and shatter the
whole the great element would be lacking
in creation he's not actually talking
about humans beings there he's actually
talking about angels and devils even
them even they had a purpose in the
great whole he says again if there were
no souls whose decision to sin or not
sin with no way also the order of the
whole an important element would be
lacking
so there are rational Souls lower than
the higher souls in their function that
equal in nature and then he talks about
a lot of other possible functions the
basic idea behind this whole argument is
that by creating creatures that have
free will and by knowing what he was
doing ahead of time in creating them God
was making the best kind of universe
that was possible even when we screw up
all time even though we live out a
legacy of all sorts of other people
having screwed up our scripts ourself or
sometimes you know they're a product of
our free will but they're also a product
of all the pressures that all the other
people before us screwing up put a pause
that's that's another possible way to
try to reconcile
divine foreknowledge and approval I know
it's a little bit hard to see but that's
where we leave a lot